[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits a podcast where
two lifelong friends talk about life for
a long time i'm link and i'm rhett this
week at the round table of dim lighting
we are going to be talking all about our
new television show insight eats with
rhett and link on food network and this
isn't and discovery plus this isn't like
a
i mean we're obviously going to be
talking about the show on all other
things that we do and trying to get you
to watch it this is not a promotion this
is not a promotional thing this is a
this is we're two guys you know us rhett
link we're friends we own a company
together and we try to make things
happen in the media landscape and one of
the exciting things that's happening for
us personally is this television show
yeah so we're gonna care enough about us
to care about the stuff that we care
about well turns out we
we're pretty excited about this
you know it's i mean we've had a few
milestones in our career that were
television shows
we had we had one
online nation in 2000 what nine so eight
seven
well i just kind of guess i you know
you're my safety net
of numbers and time 2007. and then
uh commercial kings on ifc you can get
2010. no 2011. oh
are you serious like 2011 is like the
year we moved to to california because
of that television yeah it's so many
almost 11 years so many memories but
we're gonna be talking about like how
does this happen 2021 we got another one
how does one find themselves on a
television show and then what happens
when you
begin to produce said television show
like what are the steps in this process
and what did we learn and how did we
feel
i will say promotionally speaking that
the first episode
is out
i mean depending on when you're
listening to this
more may be out
but um 10 30 on sunday nights on food
network because if you're listening to
the super fresh like the day this
episode drops it was last night was the
premiere right is that right yeah
because this comes out on a monday
typically yeah yeah so 10 30 sunday
night i was wearing this shirt in the
premiere episode i just thought i'd do
that oh
there you go
i thought i'd you know i thought i'd
make it interesting the discovery
versions are extended versions slightly
extended versions of
the same episode so it's not we it's not
bonus footage it's um
some of the scenes are extended you
don't have to fit into some extra stuff
in there
um so yeah i'm also ready to party just
as a side note i see you got your party
suit on where haven't you seen that i
got my new party suit yeah like you kind
of look like a guy that was
just cleaning a floor right i could be
working uh
he's like is he gonna is he cleaning up
after us
or does he own the company
yeah well and people can't see the can't
see
the fact that it matches it matches you
the bottoms match it's a it is a suit it
is a janitorial suit
good lord why is this here
well where did you pick that up
instagram
i do all my shopping on instagram man
shout out to imperfects
that's what this is called
um are you gonna button it up later
because if you button up you look like
you're ready to start mopping i'm gonna
i'm gonna button it up when i get to
work tonight on the turntables yeah we
we have a party tonight
christmas party so we have not been able
to come together as a company as the
greater umbrella of mythical so
everybody in mythical everybody is smosh
we wanted to obviously have a holiday
party in 2020 that didn't happen we
obviously wanted we planned the
christmas 21. in 2021 we planned a
christmas party and then the week before
it omicron just like went buck wild yeah
just butt wild so we i thought for the
longest time i thought it was butt wild
i think you can say that
i mean it's a different thing we were
going to go
halloween halloween christmas holiday
but wild and everybody throwing some
halloween we were going to do a horror
themed uh
sweater competition so it wasn't just
your your typical
you just said horror themed it was
horror themed because i pay attention to
the to the prompts um i knew we were
just no i know we had a tv show in 20 uh
2007 2011 and now 2022. and also for the
2021 holiday party the prompt was to do
a horror themed
crazy sweater because we didn't want to
do an ugly sweater because that's like
five years ago right that's pretty
pandemic
you're right about this yes
so a christmas horror though not
halloween
yeah yeah it's okay that's what makes it
cool well we're not doing that tonight
we told him to save it for for next
christmas party in our meeting the other
day when we were talking about this
christmas party or the or the the spring
party
uh emily was like
can we bring her she she apparently
worked very hard on her sweater because
we said she was like can i bring my
sweater and i was like i know a lot of
you worked very hard on your horror
themed sweaters i'm very excited to see
them but please hold them until the 2022
holiday party
so at the end of the year we get to
hopefully they won't be too dusty things
are going to break on their horse
sweaters i'm sure because people build
them you know they didn't build them for
a year they built them to like use that
night and now they're like hanging up
somewhere you forget where it is
by the time the next christmas party
rolls around but yeah and we're going to
change the theme it'll be
not scary it'll be like happy sweaters
no but we'll stop giving away
encouraging sweaters cash prize
people really stepped up for that i
think
and then you had to can it so how do you
i do want to check in and see how you
feel about uh because i have anxiety
about this and if i have anxiety about
this
then you have even more reason to have
anxiety about this
we have not been with all these people
oh
um and there's like 125 plus of them
they're going to be at this party
in the who work at mythical
uh we've hired a bunch of people over
the course of the past two years
i don't know what percentage of them i
have actually met
yeah out of the percentage that i have
actually met i don't know how many i
would be able to recognize with
seeing the bottom half of their face and
then remember their name
uh jen are we doing name tags
we're doing name tags yes i requested
that yesterday because of this
right how big are the name tags gonna be
are they going to be so big that people
can't tell that you're looking at them
we need to do like like cleavage no we
need to do like second life type things
oh it's
it's a name tag that hovers above your
head very very large so people can't
really tell if you're looking in their
eye or looking at their name tag
i love it
do we have time to do that in the next
uh eight hours
yeah i think may i think maybe uh my
suggestion would be some sort of like uh
like an old hanger like old hangers uh
secured with duct tape to the shoulders
and come up above the top if everybody
would do that before the party will be
great
hey i'm with you know i'm with you man
cause i have that name fright
oh yeah i saw it begin to emerge in the
uh the company-wide meeting the other
day yeah when you pointed at one person
and said a different name
yeah i was like i was recognizing ammo
for his uh uh his promotion
and i
i pointed at zach
yeah i mean listen brother and then i
said if you squint you guys look alike
and i don't know if that made it better
uh yeah i mean yeah you should probably
kept that to yourself i don't know man
so yeah i was a little nervous about
that but i know we're doing a name tag
so i'm cool with that
and uh i i am dj in this party oh i
heard that did oh that's why you're
wearing the outfit yeah that's my dj
outfit but i don't and my name is dj
rhett by the way
well okay hold on no your name is dj
strawbeat no my name is dj rec i'm m.c
sky and i may rap
at any point that i did not name myself
that but i think it was uh friend jaden
like i was talking about
like liking to make playlists
and i think he i think it was an
accident like he's a close friend so it
rarely happens but
so when he called he said dj rhett
i think he was thinking my name was
rhett for a second he had a brain fart
yeah even though he knows us really well
we didn't have any tags on it we like
busted out laughing this is like three
years ago pre-pandemic
and um we just busted out laughing and
he said from then on
he stored my name in his phone as dj
wrap
that's kind of funny man to kind of own
the fact that he really
royally screwed up all right dj rhett is
uh but by that by djing you mean i'm
still working on my dj name but you're
you're creating a playlist and then
walking around in the party you're not
staying behind a booth i'm not really
djing and i don't want anybody to know
that you're curious
i'm curating the playlist
and i don't want anybody to know that i
have aspirations to be a dj because i
don't want that to get out
will you have on your phone because i
don't have any dj equipment in the
moment yet the ability to take requests
or to
skip songs hell no well hold on i'm not
saying did did you have the willingness
i said do you have the ability is your
phone going to be controlling the
playlist as you walk around on your
person
um no
are you lying
yes it's a yeah no i'm not it's a laptop
dude are you lying yes it's a laptop
well at least we're being honest
it's a laptop you really can't
without the proper equipment
you can't
really dj
i mean like making a playlist is just
like a hack way to do it because that's
not really that's not
it's not dj that's the only level of
djing that i am
actually
comfortable endorsing though
really what do you mean
for this part sourcing
yeah i don't want to seem like i don't
like we did a party one time in the park
because we're doing it in the parking
lot
and we
did it before in the parking lot
and we had a real dj who was like at the
thing was that the booth was at the
turntables yeah and i just felt like it
was unmemorable it may have gone may
have been too yeah high key for us
well i'm taking some risks
oh really um playing some controversial
uh artists no uh i'm i'm going for a
vibe that i don't know that oh people
are going to be
too expecting too low-key you think
maybe it's too late i think there's a
risk of that i'm not risking going too
hard do you have some like just jim
brickman just piano music no it's not
it's not going to be does everything
have a b no one's going to go to sleep
everything has a beat
but yeah do you have an audible playlist
you like i can call an audible yeah like
change it not like you start playing a
book on tape
can you just start playing sapiens
six o'clock everyone wanted that book i
got up and i was i was working on it i
worked for an hour on a a backup
yeah in case like a vibe change in case
i was wrong yeah i think that was really
smart and um and then when i was driving
in i came up with another backup
so i'm trying to come up with
well you got to back up to the backup
yeah i just don't you know this is a
learning process let people know that
that's why i don't want anyone to know
that i'm actually doing the music at all
like i'm not even gonna i'm gonna i'm
gonna be part of the party and then i
want someone to say oh hey i like to
play music yeah it's just who made the
playlist like i've said before and then
you're gonna there's no dj
you're gonna say well dj rat did
yeah and then i'll just acknowledge it
and be like yeah you can't take cr if if
people like it you can't take credit
well if you say that dj red is not rhett
well
are you going to explain that to
everyone no
unless it's going really really well is
there it's not going to be it's not
about the music and that's the that's
the vibe i've chosen it's not about the
music it's about reconnecting with
everyone for the first time and is there
a microphone and a pa system i don't
there's a p yeah there's a p it's not
just going to be compute i know that i
just want to make sure that um i do know
very little though
but this could be the end are we going
to be making a speech is what i'm
getting or the beginning of something
well that's your problem
you worry about the speech
well no that's the problem i want you to
worry about the speech because i don't
want you to be doing the speech in the
moment i'm also going to be that's when
the party could go real sideways yeah
because i'm going to be uh partying too
yeah i'm not in full work mode
i'm just doing work attire
i'm not cleaning up messes either but i
could
i could shave down a surfboard that's
what i like to think this is like a
worker who works on shaving down
surfboards
that's what the model i've watched a few
of those wearing this i watched a few of
those and i just bought it and i've
never seen that
that's the guy was wearing it doing that
and i was like that's who i want to be
let's talk about the television show but
first let's talk about something else
just want to remind you there's other
podcasts trevor talks too much is one of
them
his guests are surprising and delighting
and they connect with him you should
give it a shot if you've never listened
to trevor talks too much and while
you're at it
best friend's back all right the stevie
hosted podcast check that one out too if
you haven't already totally different
vibe
than trevor talks too much kind of a
similar vibe to what we do here two
friends connecting
over their past getting nostalgic about
the 2000s in their case so friendship is
blossoming if you're into that
a blossoming friendship
check that out and
if you want to watch our old television
show commercial kings commercial kings
can't say it right yeah i'm going to
promote that too that's interesting
you can watch it on amazon
i believe it's on amazon prime for free
could be wrong but i think that's right
just search commercial kings with
written link and catch up on our 2011
television show
yeah
okay
how does how does one uh get a
television show this was not our idea so
let's start there
you know um we are developing
lots of ideas for for all types of what
we call traditional entertainment that
means
movies television shows of the scripted
variety and also
of the non-scripted variety could be a
game show could be a reality show it
could be a mixture of both we're
developing all types of stuff because
we're fans of ideas
especially our own
but
we're also open to other people's ideas
if they work for us like ronstat is a
great scripted podcast idea that did not
originate with us but uh it was it was
really exciting to get on board right so
every once in a while
people come along and say hey here's an
opportunity for
you guys to be involved in this project
and that's how this happened so there
was a show that was already in
development and not just in development
like it had been green lit by food
network to be a show as far as i
remember yeah but i when you say in
development i kind of feel like it was
pitched they were like yes
um the
concept at the time this
the working title was
inside our favorite or inside your
favorite
i think it was inside our favor inside
our favorite with dot dot dot and our
name was thrown out in like the pitch
meetings
would
food network discovery plus what do you
guys think about rhett and link they
could they could be perfect hosts for
this thing um inside our favorite you go
behind the scenes
into
the the first way it was talked about to
us was the people factories
where
all these people were working behind the
scenes unlike factory lines to create
your favorite snacks and candies
things like that so
it was kind of like how it's made but
more host on the
on the ground kind of exploring and
experiencing
um
what's going on at these snack factories
and then
we were approached and when we were
approached
i think it's it's important to kind of
establish the way that we see
opportunities like this right
an opportunity to
host a television show
um
i would say
10 years ago it was like that's why we
were in this game we we were doing what
we were doing on youtube to try let's
say 12 years ago kind of launch into
yeah because once gmm started kind of
launch into something in the traditional
space
but over the years what we've built here
at mythical and the stuff that we're
producing has become the priority for us
and so opportunities like this don't
they no longer have this oh this is the
thing that we've always been waiting for
we've always been wanting and now we're
gonna
throw our time into this and throw
everything else away it's more like
okay we're not going to stop doing good
mythical morning we're not going to stop
doing this podcast we're not going to
stop doing all the things that we're
doing in mythical so the question is
can we make this work because it's not
just a done deal that it's automatically
a good idea right we have been
approached for other things that we have
said no to
but the condition for saying yes to
something like this was
we will do this
if we can be executive producers of the
show and mythical can be a production
entity on on the show so in other words
if we can make it our show instead of
just being plugged in as hosts now we
were approached not by food network
directly but by the production company
that
hatched the original idea
and got food network
on board and excited about it like that
production company is called b17 they've
produced a number of other shows you
should check them out you should uh look
them up
so uh b17
approached us
yep and
uh their executive over there his name
is wrath his name is okay we have a
connection he might be maybe some
confusion he may be a dj no
he never brought that up i don't know
you don't know that people don't wear it
on their sleeves well if he did he'd be
called dj link
true okay well that clears it up i
thought about
i don't know i'm not even going to tell
you
that i've thought about other dj names
because i just don't want to put it i
just don't want to put too much energy
out there in the universe about my
aspirations i want it to be something
that just kind of
never happens or it just happens on my
own terms so i'm gonna stop talking
about it good
that
but yes and they had they had experience
um b17 had experience with uh you know
making shows with trade like internet
talent
um and we liked what they had done we
liked them and the thing is is that i
kind of set it up like we're only gonna
say yes if we get to be like create the
creative force behind the show or
whatever made it sound like pills well
but the thing is is that i don't think
we were that's what b17 and food network
wanted
in other words it's like you don't want
a host who's just like i'm going to come
in here i'm going to do my thing and i'm
going to leave you actually want
somebody who's like no no we want to be
involved we want to make the show our
own we want to be engaged we want to be
passionate about this thing yeah and
also
um
we're really really
really busy and
we can devote uh about a day
to shooting an episode
just fyi you know what i'm saying yeah
um
and and it wasn't like oh no we can't do
that it was like well okay actually
that's what we were thinking too because
you know with all the stuff that's being
made in the world right now
uh
they're not just throwing out
massive amounts of money for the budgets
on these shows right it's like people
are trying to make shows much more
efficiently than they used to so being
able to produce something in a day or
shoot something in a day is actually the
page that everybody was already on so
then we started asking the question like
all right this loose concept uh it
totally makes sense why they would
approach us we've tried all this food
we've eaten all these snacks we we've
we've kind of positioned ourselves as
your buddies behind the desk who eat all
the stuff for you just tell you if you
should eat it yeah people who taste
things and talk about it right not chefs
if i didn't have to clarify that
uh
i didn't think i had to clarify that yes
uh but not chefs but
food
adjacent or well actually directly
related to food but not guys who make it
just guys who eat it just like you food
friends um
and then the process started was like
well could have called it that food
friends well we got close to calling it
something fair it was called something
else at one point we can get into that a
little bit there was a couple of things
happening sort of behind the scenes and
so
there was a desire to differentiate
differentiate this from just kind of
going into a factory
and just dealing with snacks it was like
can we expand that into just america's
favorite food brands so that might be a
restaurant it might be somebody who
makes us a snack
but just a
a food
or a place that makes food that everyone
kind of knows and relates to and has
some sort of point of reference to yeah
which is kind of our mentality on good
of the good morning the more we can pull
from
and experience
well-known
brands whether that's
fast food brands and you know sit-down
restaurant brands or
different types of potato chips or
cereals or you know whatever stuff you
can find in the grocery store or on the
snack aisle like there's that connection
that
there's people that are passionate about
certain things and we're very passionate
about certain things so tapping into
that passion and then saying okay well
let's peel back the curtain and show you
behind the scenes there but there's so
much more than just that whole factory
thing anyway that like this show can be
more expansive and then it got more
exciting
and then we had the idea to like
how did we sort of rhett and lincolnize
this thing in terms of we knew that we
wanted it to be
very comedy forward right and we also
knew that we wanted it to be very
curiosity forward because those are kind
of the two pillars of our brand
curiosity and comedy
and so
that was when we established this idea
of what if there was sort of an off the
wall sort of out of left field question
that we
want to ask about this particular brand
like when we think about chipotle
this is what we think when we think
about cheesecake factory this is the
question that comes to mind for us and
then can we craft an episode around that
question kind of getting
going behind the scenes to answer that
question before chipotle or cheesecake
factory became
actual episodes do you remember the
first
example we talked about i do remember
because i came up with it in a phone
call
yeah it's like you know it's we were
having these working meetings with b17
me you
stevie and our development executive at
the time mallory we were you know we
were kind of like shaping it it was it
was fun
and so we were coming up with i remember
it was a very preliminary conversation
we were talking about this like line of
questioning being inquisitive
and
could one question
become
like
a starting point for an episode or maybe
a through line for an episode
but when you're brainstorming
when you speak in abstract terms
you can only get so excited
and
so the if if in those moments on those
like
nascent calls
we can throw something out there that it
that you can rally around it makes all
the difference in the world
and so that's when
you threw out
the example i don't remember the how i
phrased the question she said you
remembered it no i remember i know the
question the question was about the
foldy chip
yeah like say we're going to
um
a
potato chip factory
to look at like we're a big fan of lays
let's see we could go to a lace potato
chip factory and i think the question
was essentially
how did the foldy chips happen and
how does this brand feel about the foldy
chips and that came from the fact that
you have talked about how you like the
foley chips you prefer the foldy chips
you go after the foley chips i've even
said i want a bag of nothing but foldy
chips and i ain't talking about kettle
cakes but i think the question trips
what i had in mind was
is the foley chip a mistake or is the
foldy chip a beautiful mistake or is the
foldy chip
like is it an accepted error or is it
part of the design
so right and and how yeah how do how do
the how do the executives how do the
like executive chefs at the potato chip
factory or like the quality control
people you know it's we started
salivating over these answers right and
um everybody on the call
got excited about it so that
can't became the clarion call
of the curiosity associated with
inside eats even though we weren't
calling it and then of
course as it as this was developing
first of all everybody was like yes this
is great um
now the process of you gotta be making
phone calls to you know b17 is reaching
out to all these brands because you'd be
like hey these two guys here you can go
to their youtube you can see who they
are they're going to come to your place
and they're going to sort of like go
behind the scenes for this food network
show
and
i mean not everybody is comfortable with
us
coming into their
you know finding out about what they're
doing and but in some ways
i would say most brands were excited
about it because i mean
let's just face it you're going to be
after you watch an episode
you're going to be hungry for whatever
this thing is but
i mean you have to sell that because the
show doesn't exist and
you know there is a level of trust that
a brand has to put on the line and it's
so easy for especially when you get to
like
like corporatize brands like someone as
big as chipotle could easily have you
know
somebody's job's on the line they just
they could just want to cover their own
ass and say well
there's just as much to lose as there is
to gain if what if these guys embarrass
us you know i don't know exactly what
this show is but it is food network and
i do i can't see other things these guys
have done and you know 17 did a good job
good boys
i mean
we should talk some some some food on
our show just because hey you got to be
honest about what you like
but
yeah luckily um some very high profile
brands like chipotle is huge you know um
to to see
to get the vision for it and say hey
this is this is this could be great for
us and everybody could win and we had to
find four brands so just to give you
just to give you a little background on
this so right uh you know season one of
inside eats is four episodes let me know
four episodes that's a short that's just
that's how
um discovery or food network is doing
things right now it's like you know the
first episode my first season let's do
four episodes see what people think at
least they didn't order a pilot and then
maybe we work on that and then no one
sees it if they don't like it it's like
they're gonna we're gonna make an order
it's i feel like it's kind of an
extended pilot because four is is a
short season
but i think it's you really learn a lot
as we'll talk about
that then you can you can really
take it
take all that into account
when you when they order more and i
certainly hope they do
yeah well because we learned we'll get
into like how much we've learned in just
doing the first four but
so the brands that responded uh
actually
more than a handful of brands responded
and said they were into the idea and the
four that ended up working out based on
like timing because this all had to
happen this moved very quickly
and it had to happen at the end of 2021
we shot
all four episodes over the course of
about two weeks and literally like i
said four actual days of shooting like
two days in a row and then like two
weeks later two more days right before
christmas
um and the companies that we ended up
going with were chipotle cheesecake
factory cool house ice cream which is a
very cool
uh ice cream shop that actually is
available nationwide uh you probably
have seen them at the grocery store but
they're basically next to like ben
jerry's and then beyond meat who we've
talked about on the show
you know basically making plant-based
meat products and they had never had
anybody enter sort of behind the scenes
but anyway those are those are the four
that are featured in in season one
and for the first episode since that's
the one that you can watch right now
the thing that we talked about because
because
this is something that we've sort of
talked about tangentially before
is this like
when you go to chipotle are you a
burrito guy you're a bowl girl you uh
uh quesadilla kid whatever i'm not
saying that that's who gets those things
i'm just are you a salad robot yeah
and
we
wanted to ask the question
does what you order at chipotle say
something about your personality and
maybe more specifically
does your personality
can we know things about your
personality and then predict what you're
going to get at chipotle
yeah and at least in the least we
thought
well that'll be it'll be fun to try
yes and it works so very much in the
same way that we approach things on gmm
where we delve into
research and science but we do it from a
comedic standpoint
that is
that's really how we approach the the
show especially that first episode
because it was kind of a social science
question for cheesecake factory we knew
we had make the episode ultimately about
the bigness of their menu how could
their menu be so large
like
why but also how if you think about it
that's a it's a crazy amount of dishes
to come out of one kitchen that then is
replicated
in all the all their different locations
it's it's pretty wild
and then for
cool house
because they
had i mean arguably pushed the flavors
of ice cream just as far if not farther
than any other ice cream maker
i mean that inspired us to say well how
far is too far
and would they let us
develop our own ice creams to d to
answer the question
how far can you push ice cream flavor
like what is the limit that you can push
it to when have you crossed a threshold
because you know we're willing to cross
just dance all over that line
in each other's graves
if they uh you know whoever loses the
competition and then and beyond meat the
question was essentially what is
like
what is this process that leads to them
being able to mate something make
something that is so meat-like and
something we were very specifically
interested in
is
don't you have to still have a
familiarity with meat and like
understand meat and sort of like meat
because what beyond meat is trying to do
they're actually making a product for
people who like to eat meat but would
like to have a meat alternative either
sometimes or eventually all the time
yeah but they're not trying for uh
health reasons or dietary reasons for
environmental reasons right so they
actually
they're banking on the fact that humans
generally like the taste and texture and
color
of meat
but not everybody wants to eat that much
actual meat so how do you do that in a
plant-based way and for me personally
i mean i enjoyed like legitimately enjoy
the process at every single place
the beyond me episode for me
was the one it just gets very it gets
very scientific it gets
yeah it's very specific and like oh
that's this is how it happens now
there's a lot of surprise and awe but
there was also for that episode
because this is all proprietary stuff
like you they and they had never let
anybody in they never let cameras in
their headquarters before
and so there's like a woman who's like
looking at the whatever's in the frame
and making sure there's not some like
secret formula in the back you know
because there's there's competition out
there with with plant-based meats and so
we got a lot of information but we
didn't get enough where you could be
like i'm gonna start my own
uh beyond me now no we we got all the
information but then at the very end
there was that
men in black moment you remember uh on
the way out yeah i think that was just
like a tussy deodorant that somebody
held up in front of us
a tussy deodorant you know tussy tussy
tussy that's my favorite brand of
anything
and it kind of is like circular ssy
tussy well the great thing about tussey
is wait can we can we do an inside eats
on tussey well i hope so can we talk
about how we used to take
a sharpie and change the tea to a pea no
we do not you do not eat tussy it's a
deodorant
can you eat tussy okay season two of
inside i won't even say hello
i'm not even gonna say it man um
so we're
we're deciding that this is gonna be our
approach let's let's move to actually
actually filming these things
because it was you know it's
you get first of all coming out of the
pandemic there's i mean still a lot of
safety protocols a lot of mass being
worn up into the second of us actually
being on camera lots of testing
happening super safetyness well i want
to talk about the team that was kind of
working behind the scenes as well to
kind of get make it where when we showed
up everything was going to go as
seamless as possible so
our showrunner tj champ chambers um who
is
you know
i would say
more so than us the hardest working
person in in this whole endeavor right i
mean that dude
worked his ass off to help make this
show happen because he's basically
worrying about everything from the very
beginning to the very end of like
delivering the trailer oh yeah you know
shaping and protecting the tone of the
show and really
shepherding
our wishes
and the network's wishes and creating
something that is not a compromise but
is the best of both worlds yeah and he's
kind of a jack of all trades in a lot of
ways because he is a writer you know
he's a writer he's a producer he's a
director there's a lot of things that
are happening
behind the scenes and then when we're
producing it and he's more of a yeah
like lots of comedy experience well and
because what we knew we wanted
right
because our experience with commercial
kings now if you go back and watch
commercial kings as as uh uh
link asked you to do earlier
um
which i guess is on amazon yeah uh
you'll see there was a very specific
convention that we used back then called
otf on the fly interviews so the way
that we would the way that we would
shoot that show is we would go we would
uh work with the business we would make
the commercial and then we would kind of
along the way take stock of like what
just happened and
can we just get stand you guys in front
of this building right here and ask you
some questions so you can look like a
reality show just like they do on the
bachelor or survivor or whatever yeah or
every hgt you just talk about what is
happening in the present tense we'll use
that to sort of piece the story together
we knew that we did not want to do that
for like seven different reasons number
one i don't like that convention i don't
i i feel like it's done a lot it's kind
of overdone
but also it traps you into whatever you
said in that moment it ends up seeming
kind of canned we like voiceover we like
being able to look at what we have done
look at what has been created look at
the footage that we actually have and
then make decisions about how we want to
piece it together and it's also an
opportunity to really nail the comedy
and change jokes because you're not
going to go back out to that building
and stand in front of it again but you
can just simply voice over something
different well on commercial kings we
were really burned because we got into
the edit process and we were like we
really need to cut to an interview guys
introducing this next thing or bridging
from idea a to idea b
and there was a lot of heavy lifting
from a story standpoint that then we
just had to go out
into like
some nondescript north hollywood
location from our edit bays
and
spend a few hours just standing out
there acting like
we were we were back in nevada in nevada
or
reno or i guess we went to other places
besides nevada
reno is in nevada tonopah um
and it just
it was a lot of work and it wasn't and
it
it's not our best work no no no it's
really hard to do especially as two
people because in that we ended up
scripting them and that's when it got
just so that we could get it done and
then it was like and with the voiceover
knowing that it's scripted is just
everyone everyone knows of course yeah
you guys are now reading this thing that
you've written it's narration and it's
and people it's more of an acceptable
convention
and more flexible all those things but
we actually decision we ever made we
brought
uh nick lopez if you if you're like a
hardcore gmm trivia enthusiast you might
know that that nick was well first of
all we got to know we got to know nick
because nick was a writer's assistant
on buddy system season two
yep
and we loved him
hired him onto the gmm writing team yep
he quickly uh
i think he was a writer's assistant at
some point on gmm quickly uh moved into
a head writer position
and
uh but he went to work on other projects
talented he's had the opportunity to
kind of just move on to other things and
work on other things but
we were like he'll come back and work on
gmm from time to time when we need an
extra hand but we were like and i think
it was stevie stevie's idea was like oh
we should talk to nick
because
he understands our voice the show is not
written per se
but
if you're gonna go into like oh we're
going into this situation where there's
this guy
who is the head chef at chipotle and
we're going to be asking a bunch of
questions
nick is able to be like here is some
path that you can go down here's some
conversational paths you can go down
here's something you might want to ask
here's a little fun fact that you might
want to bring up here's something that i
know that he knows because we got it
from a pre-interview that you might find
a way to reveal in the conversation like
you can get at this in a funny way so
nick did a lot of work there along with
tj
to kind of
like when we got to set on that first
day which chipotle was the first episode
that we shot as a matter of fact yeah uh
i'll just say
my i had a my back you know this is what
happens a lot of times with me when
we're moving into a new project that's
right
my lower back goes out and it's just
something that i haven't quite got a
hold on and i don't know why it always
happens
but my back stress heads yeah i know
that's why it happens but i don't know
specifically i don't know how the
mechanically all this stuff happens
but my back had seized up and it was
like a nine on a scale of one to ten in
terms of
how bad my back can hurt so whenever you
see
rhett walking that whole episode my back
is he's walking i am in extreme pain
that whole episode
but i will hand it to myself i did a
good job of
setting us like compartmentalizing the
pain in terms of like when we were in a
conversation and just being in the
moment and trying to be in a comedic
head space that sucks man um but i mean
it's like
like a almost like a migraine almost you
know
migraines are worse migraines are worse
when when you're when your head is when
the the pain is localized in your face
in your head
which feels like the center of your
person i think that's a lot more
disrupting than like yeah i am hurt my
lower back is killing me right now
but i'm still up here my face can be i
can go completely into my head and just
exist in my head like that brain on uh
teenage mutant ninja turtles yeah krang
yeah
yeah that's basically i was i was
embodying or channeling crane is his
name crane
crane yeah you did good right and i was
using the crane voice the whole time if
that helps explain i was not um
in any pain i had it i had some jitters
you know it's like okay we're dusting
off the
the well the dust
not only of the pandemic but but like
experiencing an entire new crew and in a
place where it's like they're we're just
starting this thing everybody's watching
closely from a protocol covet standpoint
to like a performance to like what is
this show going to be to the network
standpoint
but
i think one of the main things that i
feel great about with this show and i
felt it very early on the first time we
shot something was
that first scene first thing we shot was
around back this guy pulls up and he's
unloading
um all of the the raw materials the
vegetables and the chicks when you see
this just chipotle just so you know when
you watch this on the show
this is probably halfway or maybe even a
little longer than halfway through the
episode when we approached this guy
unloading the stuff in the truck behind
the first thing we shot that was
literally like we had we we had we were
doing our like hair and makeup and in
inside the chipotle
that we were shooting at right and then
we were like okay this is your first
scene because again everything has to be
shot according to when things are
happening and then later it's pieced
together to make a a consistent
narrative but so yeah us walking around
that corner and making that law and
order joke
was
the very first thing we shot with uh
inside ease yeah and we're like we got a
couple of questions for you and he's
like how are you doing i was like oh you
you're gonna start with the questions
and it's like all right we're in the mix
things are this is happening and
we're off to the races
it felt
it felt great
to to say at the end of that first day
or even halfway through the first day
that
my main concern had been alleviated
which was
are we going to be in our zone are we
going to be
this ourselves ourselves are we going to
be
comfortable
confident
and having a good time
are we going to take everything that
we've
learned from good mythical morning and
even when things would change over the
years with good mythical morning the
bigger the change the more
chance that some that all of a sudden
our vibe would be off and when
everything is new your brain my brain
tends to focus it doesn't yet know what
to tune out
and what to focus on
oh there's new people in the crew
there's new cameras there's it's cold
today i don't i'm wearing something
different i'm this that and the other
your back hurts all of these type of
variables you have to be you have to
know what to tune out and what to focus
on
to just to be the
most
to be true to ourselves
and just trust
our instincts and be in that moment well
i was very very happy that this show is
you know we were never put in a position
and we never stepped into a position
that
was
that stretched us in a way
that that wasn't a good idea for me that
just because the people that we were
working with had very clearly
communicated that they understood what
makes us who we are and they wanted us
to be who we are yeah so i don't think i
ever felt any
there was never a question in my mind of
like are we going to be put into the
right circumstance to pull this off it
was more like
you know
there's a we are always doing this
little dance you know we we had watched
the most
analogous thing to this in the recent
past is the backup plan series that we
did on gmm right that was sponsored by
geico yeah when we went to the serial
factory right so got in the we we
actually the huge cereal bowl is a great
example we sent those uh we sent that
episode of the cereal bowl and uh there
was another one where we went to oh the
flavors the smell
the flavor factory
we sent those over to b17 and tj and
everybody were like
you know we've done this type of thing
before and this is sort of the vibe
right we're asking a real question but
we're doing it in a ridiculous way
there's going to be these ridiculous
asides and we're obviously entering the
situation as a comedy duo
uh i hadn't watched those in years and i
remember watching them and i remember
that night i watched them and
immediately sent those two episodes to
you and stevie because i was like hey
i didn't know how i was gonna feel you
never know how you're gonna feel about
something when you go back to it years
later because you always feel like
you've developed beyond it or whatever
yeah i was like hey this is the this is
the true north
the way that we interacted here this is
how we this is the vibe that we should
attain right this is the five we should
go for yeah
and
yeah i think we really got there i mean
there's always a little bit it depends
on what we're doing at the time
there are moments
in this type of format where we get to a
place where me and you are standing
there talking to one person and asking
them asking them questions and not doing
something
and it gets to be like two guys
interviewing one person and since
nothing is scripted again like
yes we have this notebook that's like
here's some some questions you could ask
here's what this person knows here is
the goal of this scene we had all kind
of developed that and then nick and tj
had put it in this big binder that we
were given when we got on set so we
could reorient ourselves but when the
camera starts rolling
you don't remember what the binder said
you you remember bits and pieces of it
but you're really going on instinct and
so yeah you've got what you're thinking
i've got what i'm thinking
oh link just said that i'm gonna go with
that or that makes me think this i'm
gonna get out of his way for a second
there's this
debt there there's a balance in trying
to figure out that dance again yeah the
brain gets hot but there's a lot going
on it pretty much came back
immediately it wasn't like a struggle
very glad about that so i think what you
know
so when we were bringing
our comedic sensibility and our
curiosity to the table into every scene
having structured the episodes and got
an approval on that the thing
that
food network was bringing what to us was
an education on
their expectations from their audience
because this is this is a melding of
two audiences
you know between a food network
discovery plus and mythical beasts and i
would say
i would say specifically food network
which yes food network is a part of
discovery
but
when we got approached
we actually didn't know
i don't know if i missed it or if it
developed later but we didn't know that
it was a food network show it would the
the conversation was discovery plus
so right
it i knew it was going to be
food-centric because that's the whole
point of the show
but the moment that it either became or
i
yeah it became clear that it needed to
be food-centric right and when we say
food-centric what we mean is that so a
person who has decided to turn on food
network and maybe you're one of those
people
um
if you're like me
you're just the kind of person that just
likes to look at food right you like to
look at food and see people make food
and see people eat food because
you have a love affair with food
i it's probably the best thing on earth
besides what rhymes with
tussy
that we talked about earlier
um
and so
people who watch
the food network they need to see food
right they don't just want to see two
guys being stupid being funny yeah
because if you're if you're a food
network first if you're tuning in for
food network first and not reading link
first you're like i'm here for the food
part of the network
i don't want these two guys to get in
the way of the food
and so there was a there was a
there was one guy who had a sort of a
specialized camera it was a different
camera that could uh do a really high
frame rate for slow motion
and he was the
food
camera guy yeah and so if the guacamole
is being made or dipped out of something
or
steak is being chopped it's like that's
when those sort of hero shots or
whatever you want to call them slow-mo
sort of dramatic food shots
he was getting all
and as he was getting all this footage
me not really understanding the show
that we were making yet i was like wow
he's filming a lot he's filming all this
food
but like i mean he's gonna be that's on
camera right
you know it's like i mean it's gonna be
the funny guys on camera right
so there was a there was there was a
realignment that happened in terms of
like
understanding the
where everything should settle what the
balance should be
for this show
and really begin to understand and
getting that food network education that
hey the the audience wants to indulge
with their eyes
you know and now you can yeah we can
have fun all along the way but you want
to indulge and you want to learn so as
we were in the you know post phase
of editing everything together and
we were giving a bunch of notes about
like all right i remember saying this
and we had it was funny
or i remember rhett said this they're
like there's three things from rhett
there's nothing for me
let's have a little bit more balance or
vice versa like we would give these type
of notes right or this is a runner
i think we can have a throwback you know
comedy notes
uh yeah the thing that we're interested
in and then we then the food network
notes would be like we need we need to
understand more of the process that you
started making the guacamole but we
don't know what the final
you didn't reveal what the final
ingredient was it didn't come together
it's like you gotta you gotta have
if you're gonna go into this guacamole
moment well it needs to have a beginning
middle and in you gotta have a
satisfying conclusion so that people
feel like
they've got the full guac experience and
it totally makes sense and you want to
see the guac and hey if there's a fact
about how many avocados
chipotle
uh goes through in a year or a week or
whatever that fact was
that's an interesting thing so we didn't
ask that in scene but we can pull a
voice over
we can change that and whenever you
start to learn these things like well
now let's add another layer
where
we're doing some some animations
that illustrate the things that you're
learning from a culinary standpoint and
i think the point that was added to the
show i think the point of this
like
what i'm hoping that you listening will
take from this this discussion
um is
you know if
we made
this this show and we were making it for
good the good mythical morning audience
we were going into the into chipotle and
asking this question and then putting it
on to an episode of gmm or as an episode
of gmm like we did with the backup plan
because you're tuning in to good
mythical morning we think primarily to
hang out with us then it's going to be a
bun it's going to be almost like 90 to
95 just us being us and using this
canvas of chipotle as an opportunity to
be funny right yeah
but because the intended audience is
first and foremost
someone who's interested in food
television food network
it is a food show first that we are then
bringing all that rhett link
ridiculousness and curiosity
into
uh to kind of create more of a balance
so while i do think it is the most
uh i don't want to say it's the funniest
show on food network i mean i think guy
fieri is very funny
uh but i think it is the most like
intentionally comedic
show on food network you know and shout
out to alton brown who we still want to
have on gmm yeah yeah yeah uh you know
he had he did more of the like this
sketch thing at the top of
his show
or one of his shows and
you know that that's another thing that
we we did
succeed at starting with comedy like
there's basically
well let me clarify i just made it sound
like i was saying that guy fieri is
unintentionally funny no i'm i'm just
saying that like he's coming in there
first and foremost as a chef who happens
to be very funny we're coming in as
comedians who just happen to have some
knowledge about experience oh i got you
you know what i'm saying i got you
um
but yeah i am curious that this you know
we we're
we're talking to you and kind of telling
you what our perspective is and all of
this i think has come together in a show
that makes the most sense that is
satisfying
on all of these levels you know are
there as many jokes
as we made
of course not there's lots of stuff that
got cut but there are more just so you
know
again when you're doing linear
television that's actually going to show
up on food network and have commercial
breaks
that that episode is about 22 minutes of
content right that's how much content
ends up being in a half hour block of
traditional television so you got to hit
22 minutes obviously on discovery plus a
streaming service you don't have to hit
that so
um we had these additional
sometimes a completely new scene and
sometimes just a new thing that happened
in a scene and all those have been added
in when you watched on discovery plus
and so you might get like a 25 26 minute
episode on discovery plus
and most of that is going to be stuff
that wasn't
essential or integral to a food network
audience but and so it tends to be some
of the funny
sort of tangential stuff that happened
in the moment the thing that i'm most
interested in at this point
because it hasn't premiered yet as of
this recording
is
yeah what is the reception going to be
what what are mythical beasts going to
think of it
what is the food network audience going
to think how are we going to find out
what
non-mythical beasts think like where are
we going to get that feedback i'm sure
for sure we'll find that out you know
it's like we'll have to go to other
places and other ways that the show is
posted online or
um or promos of it or posted online just
to you know to tap into that buzz but
i'm just i'm interested because
again it's like
every time you put something out for
a new type of audience it's like well
are they are they going to hate one or
both of us well i just know you know i i
just
i know that with the way that i do
things it's like i
some i'm not for everybody
i'm not for everybody so i'm kind of
prepared for that it's like
and i but i don't
and if that's the reason that show
doesn't work so be it
the showing gonna work without me i just
have to do season two alone
maybe i'll do it with dj red no it's
this is your opportunity to say people
don't like me either that's true people
a lot of people don't like me maybe more
people that don't like you right
but so there's a there's a question of
like is the
traditional sort of food network
audience going to be like i want to see
somebody who's making great food i don't
want to see a couple of idiots who are
just having fun with food
um and then on the opposite end of the
spectrum are there people who are like
i'm just coming here for the
ridiculousness of rhett and link and i
don't care about all the food shots
because we have made a show that is a
compromise between what both parties
want
i believe that i mean for me because i
do like food a lot and i like food facts
and i like to see the process it was
fascinating to get to know
the people who are making the decisions
about what ends up on the chipotle menu
or the cheesecake factory menu the
people behind these incredible flavors
at cool house the scientists the flavor
scientists behind beyond meat that's all
super fascinating stuff to me that's
personally more fascinating than me
making a joke
um
so
i feel like it landed in a great place i
do too i'm very proud of this show i was
very proud of commercial kings
and if we had the opportunity if they
had ordered more it we would have turned
a corner and it would have gotten that
much better
but the but the core of that show
was was something i'm very very proud of
and i wish they would have ordered more
i'm glad that they didn't because good
mythical morning may have never existed
uh and we wouldn't be here today but we
learned so much
in these four episodes
of figuring out what the show is and
how to ask those questions and what we
should actually be shooting and the
things that we should actually be doing
that i feel like
uh i'm not saying we have so much more
focus i'm not saying there's anything i
think what we ended up with season one
after a lot of edits and a lot of back
and forth and figuring that out we kind
of know exactly what the mode is and
what the final product is going to be
going if we can go into a second season
where i would just be that much more
confident to make a great television
show but we've we've experienced enough
to know that like you know it could go
either way we're very hopeful we believe
that this show
has legs and we want to keep making it
but
you know there's so many factors
not the least of which is who
again at this point who knows how it
will be interpreted how we will be
interpreted
within
like the food network programming it's
just very because it is it is a
different type of show that pushes the
comedy more
and it it is
it's unique
so that's a that's a good thing if if
enough people are ready for it if they
have
um pun intended an appetite for it now
i
haven't really come i haven't made a
definitive decision about this but i am
considering and strongly leaning towards
not reading anything about the show
not looking at anyone's thoughts about
the show we've never done that with
anything we've made
well why would you start now i'm getting
much more actually i'm moving in that
direction much much more i find it to be
a much healthier place because
um
while the vast majority of feedback that
we get on the things that we do is
positive because we've got such a
supportive fan base
you first of all you know that the
minority comments who are going to say
something hurtful those are the ones
that you remember
but also
i find myself not being in a healthy
place when i'm trying to find the
positive comments
to
outweigh the negative comments and then
i realize that i am finding my identity
and my value and other people's
interpretation of my work where what i'm
trying to do is get to a place where
i am happy with what this ended up being
and so that's the only thing that i need
to know is that i am proud of it i know
what i like about it what i don't like
about it my thoughts about it what i
would do differently
now we have people
who are here at mythical who are going
to tell us the
aggregate opinions of people which are
very helpful i'm not saying i don't want
to take the audience's reception into
account
because you're not a good producer if
you don't do that if you don't know what
the audience thinks
but there is something that happens
emotionally
and mentally when you interact directly
with either a compliment or a criticism
that i don't think is necessarily good
for my
psyche well
i
i applaud that i actually think
i'm talking out of both sides of my
mouth because i said that we've never
done that before but
the more i think about it i i l i read
stuff less and less like i'm
i'm kind of a
uh
what's what's the per i'm a hermit
in a lot of i'm like a social media
hermit
like i mean
you you tell me lots of things that i
don't read that i they never cross my
path
yeah so i actually you're a lot more
prone to it than i am i i think i'll
probably end up just being like
you know
i didn't end up
reading anything
well it's things like
but a new project i can be having a
different than like the ongoing stuff i
can be having a good day
and then i make the
horrible decision
to like go and look at
and i haven't done this recently i'm
just saying i'm back when it was a
relevant thing to do
um
look at the goodreads reviews for the
lost causes of bleak creek now first of
all again the aggregate of that book the
rating is very high right
i'm proud of that book obviously we're
not novelists and i didn't think it was
going to be like win the pulitzer prize
and we learned a lot in doing it
but i'm proud of what it ended up being
for what it is
but
there are people who come to goodreads
who see themselves as literary critics
and then just write these scathing
reviews and some of them you're like
well yeah that's true or yeah you're
right about that
that puts me in
but i already know what i think about
that process i already know how i feel
about that book i already know how i
feel about what we would do differently
if we were to do a a second one in the
series or whatever yeah
so you're not learning anything i'm only
suffering emotionally so
as i try to release myself from things
that i can't control which is people's
opinions about our work
what i can control is
our work right i can i have an opinion
about it and that opinion can be
incorporated into the next iteration and
it just feels like a much healthier
place so
because of all the things that you were
just saying about
yes there's gonna be people who are like
actively like
i don't want this on my on my network i
don't want these youtube idiots on my
network
for whatever reason for hang-ups that
they have or they just like you said
they don't like us they don't like our
sense of humor it's stupid whatever they
don't like the fact that you're picky
they don't like the fact that we're not
chefs
feeling they don't like my hair whatever
do i already know that there's people
who think that i already know that there
are people who think we're insufferable
do i need to hear them say it
so we also don't need them to change
their mind
right we're we're doing just fine yeah
and so i i guess what i'm saying
ultimately is i don't think i'm i'm
definitely not going to seek out any
sort of
you know i heard somebody saying one
time like never read your book review
never read your movie review like if we
ever have the privilege of making a
feature
length movie
i don't think i'm going to read any
critic reviews i don't think i'm going
to go to rotten tomatoes now i'm going
to know what the aggregate score is
because somebody you can't avoid it and
somebody's going to tell us it's going
to be in some report that comes in an
email
everyone your movie is is currently at a
61
so it's certified fresh but just barely
and uh
most of the comments are about the
choice you guys made to include
uh the scene with the dog dice and she
really shouldn't have done that whatever
you know
and so it was like yeah well we
shouldn't put that in there yeah i don't
want to overstate it either i don't want
to be like i'm just saying that like
what i've noticed a number of times is
i'll be like i'm things are good right
now and then i all of a sudden i'm
reading something i just know what the
weaknesses are i'm not saying it ruins
my day those things that you mentioned
are things that we already know people
are going to be opinionated about the
way that we look the way that i act my
the our non
chef like there's there yeah
there's some targets on our back if you
want to be critical but
those are things that i don't want to
change about myself the things that
really hurt are the things where we know
it's a weakness and we wish we could
have changed it like that's when it
really gets me is that like yeah but i
think there's but i guess there are some
of those things but those are small when
it comes to these four episodes
there's not any gaping
shortcomings yeah i agree i i feel is
like a big weakness it is what it is i
mean is that isn't it you know again
it's not i mean we're not it's
i was good honestly it's like is it are
we trying to win an emmy not no no of
course not i mean yeah i mean maybe
eventually but we don't think that this
show is not it's like i mean
some of my favorite shows ever i don't
know if they ever won an emmy
right dirty jobs ever win an emmy yeah
so i maybe so what i think it deserves
one i completely agree with you
that the stuff that i already know to be
true
um
or so it's like this person thinks this
thing they perceive us in this way like
that's not the stuff that bothers me the
stuff that bothers me is the stuff that
i already know to be to be the case
that's like like yes we made this
mistake or we did this thing wrong
and now people are basically recognizing
that in my worst fear of people finding
out that we made this mistake and did
this in the wrong way is coming true
right what i'm saying is from an
emotional standpoint i already know the
mistakes that i've made i'm not talking
about with this like i agree with you i
don't feel that way about this this show
i'm just saying in general with the
things that we put into the world i have
just found that i'm in a healthier place
when i'm like you know what was lacking
about that thing that you did do you
need somebody to tell you when you
already know and do you gain anything
emotionally from it
so
if i can have somebody else read all
that all that feedback and then come to
us and be like hey this is actually how
things were received
from a whole group that's much less
emotionally sort of unsettling than
reading individual people say very
personal things
and so
i'm not saying i can't deal with it i'm
just saying after it happens i think to
myself
i could have not i could have not
experienced that and i and i would be
having a better time right now i would
be in a healthier place
yeah um i i get it this is not
a gm 22 scenario oh and you know that of
course that's i think that's my point
yeah you know it's like we did that
first we feast snack video
and i read those comments and you get
the people who don't they're not fans of
ours who maybe don't have a point of
reference for us and yeah i do remember
the comment about me that was like this
guy just
he like he acts and eats like a
four-year-old
it's like okay
well
that's
he's
this commenter is describing something
that could have hurt my feelings but the
thing i'm the thing the way i'm trying
to grow is
is to interact with the not interact
with the comment but to
to acknowledge the comment within myself
as you know what
he's describing something that people
are attracted to about my sense of humor
and my persona yeah that he doesn't get
or doesn't prefer and it's not for
everybody and you know what so
i mean
but i but i was fully myself and i'm
very proud of it and i don't expect
everybody to like me and i remember and
i'm i would actually remember things
just trying to be cool with that that's
a good example because i remember
thinking that when we left that first we
feast
shoot
that i remember i was like a
four-year-old yeah i remember thinking
we were really ourselves
and we were having a genuinely good time
just being ourselves and interacting
with these snacks
and i am proud of what we did the only
thing i was pissed about
was
they didn't buy the right cereal
so that's why there was no cereal in the
episode and they also cut
it out your beans i did have baked beans
and that was it so just for the record
rhett eight beans and i ordered cereal
but raisin bran is not raisin bran
crunch
and that's not and by the way
raisin bran is not raisin
nut bran
okay
and that's the one i actually ordered
because i'm on that kick now raising nut
brand crunchers raisin nut bran
not raisin bran crunch but
so and i was pissed about that but you
know mistakes are made and i knew when
we came as a duo
when we came into duo and we had all
those snacks i knew that something was
going to be cut out
um but what i'm getting at is
even though i did when it came out i did
start scrolling through the comments i
stopped because i was like hold on you
remember walking out of there and
thinking to yourself
you did that the way that you wanted to
do it now anytime you venture outside of
your protective bubble of your your
mythical beast your mythical beasts
um
you know that you're you're ready you're
gonna get some criticism and so
again i was like
yes people aren't gonna like it some
people don't do some people just look at
us and are immediately annoyed i
understand i get it i know people like
that too
um right but if i'm happy with what i
did and how i came across
then i should just let that be what i
found the satisfaction in not that
somebody liked it or didn't like again
because i don't want to just hear things
that people like either i'm saying that
finding any sort of
value or currency in people liking me or
feeling undervalued because people don't
like me
i'm just trying to move to a new level
of existence and it's really difficult
for a performer who has built a career
on trying to please an audience it's
just part of the
ongoing struggle so when we've got
something like this that's
again
i don't know how many people are going
to watch the show compared to how many
people watch good mythical morning
i think less
given how many people watch good
mythical morning
but it's still going to be perceived as
some leveling up it's like the people
back home in north carolina oh they're
all excited about the tv show because it
means more to them because they think
that being on television and instead of
having a youtube show is like a
fundamentally different more awesome
thing it's just how people think about
things and so
you feel like you're stepping up onto
some
sort of
uh
pseudo pedestal
and now people are going to be like well
now that they've done this now i've got
to have my opinion and i'm just like
well i already know what i think about
what we did i already know about the
show
so i should not even hear your opinion
does that make sense
yeah
i got a little wreck for you if you want
to do some easy listening i played this
for you the other night jose gonzalez
yeah i like him he is uh
uh
swedish well he's from sweden but he's
that's what i thought from the name his
parents are argentine he's like that
sounds like a swedish name he's of
argentinian descent but he was born and
raised in
sweden and he's got this um
this
just totally soothing
just go into nature
and listen to some jose gonzalez his
last
his most recent album where's my phone
i've got so many pockets in this suit
it's in your pocket dj it's my top
pocket
listen to his album local valley just to
get some good bucolic vibes going on
man
an introspective and autumnal
folk and indie pop blend that's pastoral
in experience jose gonzalez he's got a
lot of albums you're welcome
hashtag here biscuits
let's keep the conversation going next
week
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]